I loved working in restaurants me too
dude that Jersey Mike's job you know I
have I have three favorite jobs of all
time right now the job we're doing is my
favorite yeah second one is Josh Wolf
show yeah and the third one is Jersey
miks there's something about working at
a restaurant where you where it feels
like you're on a team which we both like
I'll tell you something else dude every
restaurant I ever worked in everybody
everybody was everybody oh not
at the restaurants I worked at well you
worked at Jersey miks I feel like that
would be the restaurant where everyone
is everyone no well there's no
booze and nobody's going out and
drinking after work and it's cap who
went know drinking after work you call
me cap I said cap like cap like Captain
no the Jersey Mike crew isn't the same
as the crew that's going out but it
could be 100% I would 100% agree with
that your Jersey Mike's crew is not the
same as your typical bar crew yeah 100%
but lot lot of always a lot of fun very
volatile lot of drama which was always
fun to watch because I was I never
really got involved in it but I loved
stirring the pot